fairytales we grow up on them fantasy
stories told to us as children with a
moral or lesson made clear at the end
but those fairy tales work always as
innocent as we know them to be today
they were actually very dark violent
allegories that scared children and
adults alike take the cannibal witch
from Hansel and Gretel the trope of the
evil old lady in a creepy hut in the
woods line and wait for victims is
something we see often even outside of
the fairy tale genre the gingerbread
house baking children in ovens the
desire for human flesh a secluded
location in the woods while witches have
been associated with these
characteristics before it wasn't until
brothers Jacob and Wilhelm Grimm wrote
it all down together that this legendary
monster was made they collected their
stories from oral folklore accounts so
in order to truly understand the origins
of one of the most recognizable tales
today we need to look further in history
into the witch trials of Germany and the
famines that led people to make some
very desperate decisions it's a complex
history also stick around after the
episode for a special monstrum
announcement
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
the original story of Hansel and Gretel
was first published in Germany in 1812
with the first English translation in
1884 it tells the tale of two siblings a
boy and a girl whose family has nothing
left to eat their father a poor
woodcutter is convinced by the mother to
abandon the children in the deepest part
of the forest to starve to death her
philosophy is that it would be better to
have them killed by wild animals than to
watch them starve the first attempt goes
poorly hearing their parents plans for
them Hansel sneaks out of the house to
collect white stones the next morning
when his parents lead the siblings deep
into the woods Hansell secretly leaves a
trail of these white pebbles back to
their house Hansell and Gretel are told
to build a fire and that their parents
will come back with more wood but when
darkness falls the parents had yet to
return
luckily the moon shines bright in the
siblings follow the pebble trail home to
the happiness of their father and
disappointment of their mother again
food runs out and again the mother
insists the children should be abandoned
this time honza uses a small amount of
bread to make another trail through the
woods as their parents walk them deeper
into the dense forest for the second
time the parents leave and night falls
again but to their dismay the children
realize that birds have eaten their
bread crumb trail after three days of
wandering in the woods they stumble upon
a small house built entirely of breads
and cakes the whole thing is covered
with sweets the windows made of fine
sugar the starving Hansel and Gretel
begin eating chunks of a house when they
are startled by a little old woman who
takes them inside and serves the milk
fruit and sweets they fall asleep with
full bellies the old woman it turns out
is a wicked witch who built her house to
lure children in so she could kill and
eat them when the children wake she
throws Hansell into a small chicken coop
and she forces Gretel to do chores
including feeding her brother to fatten
him up for slaughter
Hansell manages to prolong his demise by
poking out a chicken bone for the witch
to feel when she checks his fatness
after four weeks the which tells Gretel
to check the bread bacon in the oven
secretly intending to push the child in
and bake her but Gretel manages to
outsmart the witch by tricking her into
looking into the oven herself as soon as
the old woman steps inside
Gretel quickly locks her in Gretel frees
Hansel as the witch screams before they
flee they steal her precious stones and
pearls the children manage to find their
way home and make their father a rich
man their mother has died abandoning
children and baking an old lady in the
oven what a pleasant story what could
possibly have prompted the creation of
this twisted tale well for one thing the
18:10 manuscript written by Jacob and
Wilhelm constructed a version of the
Hansel and Gretel story from one told by
dorchen Wilde who would eventually
become Wilhelm's wife
although dorchen grew up in Germany she
had French ancestry which might explain
why the story bears quite a few
similarities to the 17th century French
fairy tale led petit poussey by Charles
Perrault the story includes a poor
woodcutter who cannot feed his children
so he and his wife abandoned them
despite her protests the smallest of the
children saves himself and his siblings
from the woods once with pebbles and
tries to again with breadcrumbs an evil
cannibal ogre tries to eat them before
accidentally killing his own daughters
instead what I'm really interested in is
where the stories diverged the change of
a male ocher into a female witch for one
and why do the Brothers Grimm ad in a
house made from bread why would they
have presented the mother as the
murderous parent I have some theories
but first we need to address the element
of the story that starts off the whole
thing the Willing abandonment of one's
own children in the 18th century in
early 19th century Germany suffered from
multiple famines it was estimated there
was a 40% population loss to starvation
and disease between 1708 and 1711
another famine hit in 1771 to 72 the
grimm brothers were born in 1785 and 17
86 so they might have felt or seen the
lingering effects of these losses or at
the very least encountered older people
in their folklore interviews who lived
through these events one of the
realities of famine at this time was
that children might be abandoned or even
killed because there was not enough food
to go around some tried to justify these
deaths believing they helped ensure the
survival of the family as a whole it can
be argued the Hansel and Gretel story
served as a way to rationalize such
dramatic horrific measures during the
second half of the 18th century in
Germany it was illegal for mothers not
to report their pregnancies all other
individuals were obligated to report any
suspected pregnancies some women
believed hiding pregnancy was necessary
for their economic social and even
personal survival court records from
infanticide trials during this time
support that naming poverty fear of
punishment and fear of social shame as
the primary given motives interestingly
even though both fathers and mothers
could be accused of murdering their
children it was only mothers who were
charged with infanticide all this
historical context might explain why
does the mother in the 1812 grim story
who insists on abandoning the children
so what about the wicked witch Germany
had its own unique interpretation of an
evil cannibal monster the Kindle frezzer
or child devour served as both a fairy
tale and warning to children these
ghoulish creatures were usually
described as large hairy men with a sack
full of children it would greedily stuff
into its mouth a surefire way to keep
kids obedient
the female version of this monster
resembled the stereotypical witch an old
Hunchback with a hooked nose and messy
hair so perhaps because of this when
people in Germany were prosecuted for
witchcraft
they were often also accused of
kidnapping and eating children the whole
baking the kids in the oven aspect of
Hansel and Gretel may even have its own
explanation in my research I stumbled
across a series of German witch trials
in the 16th century where thirty-five
supposed witches were sentenced under
torture
some of them confessed to child
cannibalism and cooking infant flesh and
copper pots they also even claimed to
process the dead children's bodies and
bake them in ovens sound familiar so
we've talked about the witch but what
about the house made from bread and
sweets the words gingerbread house are
an English translation of the German
word from what I could find the Brothers
Grimm were the first people to write
this into a story with a witch they made
the real world gingerbread house popular
or rather an opera about Hansel and
Gretel did over time the house evolved
becoming an icon largely because of
Engelbert Humperdinck operatic
interpretation of the fairy tale first
performed in December 1893 the houses
described made of cake and referred to
as the gingerbread house the set design
for the Opera
reinforced the image it made something
that had only existed in the imagination
more concrete in addition to being made
from cake the house was surrounded by a
wall of gingerbread children the victims
of the wicked witch in other words he
toned down the overt cannibalism and
upped the aesthetic factor
the Brothers Grimm took oral tradition
and hundreds of years of German folklore
and made it into one of the most popular
stories of all time that continues to
frighten children to this day so when
you're constructing a house from cookies
and frosting and watching questionable
decisions by great actors you should up
remember that some things have a deeper
and darker meaning good news everybody
get ready for a lot more monsters and
myths because monstrum is returning with
even more new episodes in 2020 but
that's not all the channel is going to
grow and evolve in some exciting ways
starting with a new name storied behind
every monster book video game film and
work of art there is a story we want to
tell those stories here don't worry
monstrum is not going anywhere but we're
bringing some friends and new shows
along to join the channel hi I'm Lindsay
and I'm princess and we're bringing back
its lip PBS Digital Studios show all
about our favorite books and genres will
be joining story in February and you'll
be able to find new episodes here on
this channel story is going to be a new
home for arts and humanity shows like
monstrum it's lit and more and we want
your help to pick future shows for the
channel head over to the community tab
to vote on your favorite new show idea
one more thing a huge thanks to all of
you
it honestly means a lot to me and the
monstrum team that so many of you have
watched commented on and shared our
videos we can't wait to show you what
we've been working on
you